do you still believe test and trace is
working
she says she does but what does baroness
harding
really think we've seen leaked documents
which tell us
and it's quite different to what she
says in public
presented today by executives including
baroness harding
this slide outlines the five christmas
priorities
for test and trace in england number one
is
reset our relationship with local
authorities
two is get bigger three is get faster
and
four is improve use of data
number five is rebuild public trust
a clear admission say public health
experts
that that's gone missing what the public
knows is that the response
um has been extremely expensive and
extremely ineffective
so they have a contact tracing system
that's been centralized and privatized
using large commercial providers that
have never ever delivered contact
chasing
and what it's shown is it isn't working
this leaked slide shows how the rebuild
is meant to happen
there's a lot going on but not much in
the way of clear objectives
the relationship with local authorities
strained since the beginning of the
service
will be reset by something called
contain plan
apparently a reference to the existing
framework
for local covered response to labor
that's not really a plan at all we're
two weeks in now and we've seen
no plan at all to fixed contact racing
instead we've seen a pr plan that's not
good enough
they've got to use these remaining two
weeks of lockdown if
to if it is going to be another two
weeks to fix contact rating
a department of health and social care
spokesperson said
nhs test and trait is breaking chains of
transmission
thanks to local and national teams
working hand in glove
over 2 million people who may otherwise
have unknowingly spread coronavirus
have been contacted and told to isolate
we
are continuously seeking to improve the
service
as well as our vital local relationships
we were told test and trace would be
world beating
now most people would be happy if the 12
billion pound program was merely
competent
and with just weeks to improve even that
isn't guaranteed roland manthal sky news